how do you feel about the people that
think they know what's best for you
meaning the ugly they're like you should
do this because we know what's right for
you we're smarter we have the fancy
degrees we come with the right last
names what do you think about those
names what do you think about the
establishment do you think they know
what's best for you now you may be
watching this getting irritated same Pat
how could you ask me a question like
that I've been following the activity
for over 10 years you know I'm a free
thinker you know I think for myself you
know I like to be an entrepreneur
entrepreneur I feel we can do it better
collectively I don't like to be confined
in a controlled environment perfect so
you may say Pat I have no clue where
you're going with this just praise for
impact I'm going to explain it to you
look in life we're all going to fall in
one of three categories you're either
part of the oblivious crop I have no
clue what's going on they don't read
they don't pay attention they're just
kind of living their lives as it is
right two you're part of the
establishment you're trying to control
everybody and what they're doing you
join their camp or you're part of the
anti-establishment saying I don't know
about that I think there's a better way
of doing this I kind of don't like to be
controlled I want to find the other guys
that are free thinkers let's see if we
can do it better right so today I'm
going to make a case to you no matter
where you're living in the world if
you're free financially if you live in a
place that you get to kind of live your
life the way you want I'm telling you
it's because somebody part of the
anti-establishment movement risked their
life so you and I can have that freedom
so my case will be made on what the risk
is to be part of this side what the risk
is to be part of this side and what the
risk is to be part of the oblivious
[Music]
foreign
from this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel but if it gets
you thinking and you want to argue with
other people share it with others let's
get right into it so anti-establishment
establishment the oblivious obviously if
you're going to be part of oblivious the
world dictates what your life's going to
be like you pick and choose but if
you're part of the anti-establishment
movement you're part of the group that
wants to fight for Freedom this side
wants to control so think
anti-establishment Freedom think
establishment control Elite majority
pretty heavy topic here so bear with me
before we get started if your English is
like mine and it's not your first
language let's look at the definition of
each word as well as the synonyms linked
to these words so the word
anti-establishment is a belief which
stands in opposition to the conventional
social political and economic principles
of a society the term was first used in
a modern sense in 1958 by the British
magazine new Statesman to refer to its
political and social agenda so if we
look at synonyms and similar words to
anti-establishment you will find
alternative non-traditional
unconventional underground pioneering
state-of-the-art trailblazing those are
some of the words that are link to
anti-establishment you pick and choose
which one is yours let's look at
establishment definition of the
establishment describes the dominant
social group dle to control a polity and
organization or an institution and if we
look at synonyms or similar words to it
you will find the authorities the system
the ruling class the regime bureaucracy
status quo big brother and a list goes
on again you pick and choose do you
relate to the anti-establishment or the
establishment now let's look at the
oblivious the definition of oblivious
not aware of or not concerned about what
is happening around one and if we look
at synonyms or similar words you will
find unaware unconscious heedless
unmindful insensible ignorant blind deaf
unobservant unconcerned insensitive
detached removed I can give a few more
but I can get the idea you get to pick
and choose again are you more
anti-establishment establishment or
oblivious if you are a free thinker if
you are an entrepreneur if you are an
entrepreneur you automatically fall
under the category of anti-establishment
now having said that look if you choose
to be part of Oblivion crowd you already
know life is a little bit more peaceful
because you don't have a lot of
decisions to make the pressure's not on
you it's just kind of like I'm gonna
live my life I don't care what they do I
don't have any control over it anyways
so there's actually peace in that but
the matter somebody can control you but
there is pros and cons in both being
anti-establishment and establishment
here's what they are if you are
pro-establishment the pros are the Elite
has your back they will under report
mistakes you make they will make excuses
for you they will defend you you'll
automatically start off with a resume
their contacts are available to you
their resources are available to you and
they carry a bigger stick and they're
generally more feared than the
anti-establishment at first and by the
way the oblivious relies mainly on the
establishment because the establishment
controls the oblivious it's almost like
it's their asset the oblivious are the
most valuable asset to The Establishment
so now let's look at the con on the
pro-establishment you are a slave they
control you you have to do what they
tell you to do you give up your freedom
it's an element of being a puppet deep
down inside you feel like you have to
compromise your values and principles
now let's look at the pros of
anti-establishment you win over people
okay there's a real loyalty there you're
fighting for your beliefs you are free
you get to pick and choose which fights
you want to fight and which ones you
don't you get to make decisions that
match your values and principles you
find all the people like yourself so now
let's look at the con the con is the
elite will demonize you they have more
power than you they were over
scrutinizing in essence they'll amplify
whatever you do wrong so let's just say
if it's a two they'll sell it as a nine
the elite expect Perfection from you the
elite will spread rumors about you the
elite will make it hard for you to find
a job or compete in a Marketplace the
risk of being part of the establishment
is a hundred times bigger than being
part of the establishment if you're
still watching this you're a little bit
crazy I want to tell you this but I said
I called it this thing's not going to
get a lot of use because some people are
going to say this thing is crazy but I'm
talking to you openly and freely because
I am a guy that left Iran that lived at
a refugee camp that came to America for
one word and it's freedom and that's why
I'm fighting for it even after I've
already made my money because I know
there's other people like you out there
that are going to watch the same I
relate to this so now our case study
today John F Kennedy let's get right
into it so what made John F Kennedy
unique one day did not need to sell out
to the establishment because they had
their own money matter of fact when you
look at the campaign contribution when
he ran for office 50 percent of the
campaign's total budget came from his
father Joseph Kennedy however Joseph
Kennedy was quoted saying I'll spend
every dollar I have to get my son
elected JFK's campaign costs somewhere
around 20 to 25 million dollars in
Joseph Kennedy at the time was worth 400
million dollars in 1960. if you're
saying Pat why is that such a big deal
because most people who run for office
they don't really put any money into the
campaign I don't even know if Hillary
Clinton put any money into her campaign
it was other people that gave money
let's look at a couple other people
outside of Kennedys like Ronald Reagan
Ronald Reagan took 6.4 million dollars
out of his own money into The Campaign
which was 10 the total budget let's look
at Ross Perot who didn't win but he
self-funded 97 of his 1992 presidential
campaign he got all the way up to 21 he
didn't win but he caused Bush to lose
any cause Clinton to win let's look at
Trump when it comes down to Trump in
2016. he funded 72 percent of his 2016
presidential campaign to kind of put
that into perspective Hillary Clinton
spent more money on her campaign in 2016
and she put nothing into it just to kind
of tell you one got money from the
institutions the other one was his own
money 72 percent of it so before you get
excited about this what's the risk
there's a risk John F Kennedy got
assassinated Ronald Reagan there was an
attempt for assassination Trump
character assassination Ross Perot never
once so we would never know what would
happen to him if he spent 97 percent of
his money to go up against the
establishment so you may watch us and
say Pat I I feel like I relate to the
anti-establishment but I wish I had a
Joseph Kennedy as a father to do this
you're right I'm not sitting here and
telling you not to I'm telling you go
make your money there's three different
types of Rich the first is those that
are rich but they're boring they don't
know how to create a following could be
Bloomberg number two those that are rich
but they're willing to sell out meaning
anything for me to become president
because I want to get that status on my
title right then there are those who
have the money who are fighters who are
True Believers and who are charismatic
that last one that is very hard if you
got somebody like that that is willing
to go up against the establishment that
is very problematic because that person
cannot be controlled and they create
tens of millions of followers which
drives the establishment insane okay so
let's take a look at which one of the
establishment didn't like John F Kennedy
first one being the CIA JFK was known to
be in critical of the CIA especially
after the field Bay of Pigs invasion he
also reported wanted to reform the CIA
which he saw as being too powerful and
secretive for example after Castro led a
revolution that overthrew the Cuban
government in 59 the CIA wanted to
conduct an operation to overthrow Castro
Eisenhower did not want to make this big
of a decision so close to the end of his
presidency so the CI earned JFK to
approve the operation month after his
inauguration and it goes terribly now
JFK fires CI director Alan Dulles after
the Bay of Pigs invasion in 61. Dulles
was the director of CIA since 1953 and
JFK believed that the CIA had not been
honest with him about the chances of
success which led to him firing Richard
bezel Jr the deputy director of the CIA
and in many of JFK's biographies there's
a quote that's referenced there multiple
times I'm going to Splinter the CI in a
thousand pieces and Scatter it to the
winds and there's even a recording of
JFK speaking to a group of reporters in
1961 when he says the following I think
it's time we had a complete
reorganization of the CIA it's become an
arm of the state department instead of
an arm of the President JFK eventually
did order a reorganization of the CIA
obviously the CIA didn't like this The
Establishment didn't like this because
the CI was a good way of controlling
people the oblivious now the second one
was a mafia some people may say Pat the
mafia establishment isn't that like the
ultimate anti-establishment yes but the
mafia bought the establishment so they
became the establishment so they had to
protect the establishment so the Kennedy
family comes in saying hey if you help
us become presidents we're going to help
you out and we're not even going to look
your way and then all of a sudden they
win the mafia helps them Chicago all
this stuff next thing you know after
they win the Kennedy family's like hey
hey we kind of want to back off a little
bit RFK starts going after himself what
are you doing here you're making our
life hard then they go to the
establishment they start talking now
both the establishment and the mafia
team up to go up against Kennedy hence
the anti-establishment family next he
was not a fan of Federal Reserve and
that's purely establishment here's what
happened JFK was critical to Federal
Reserve and wanted to reform it he
believed that the Federal Reserve was
too powerful and that it was not
accountable to the American people
executive order
11110 was issued by President Kennedy on
June 4th of 1963. this was a significant
impact on the Federal Reserve the order
delegated to the Secretary of Treasury
that the president's authority to issue
silver certificates meaning that the
Federal Reserve would no longer be
issuer of currency in the United States
so what this did is it reduced the power
of federal reserve it increased the
power of the Secretary of the Treasury
it created uncertainty about the future
of the Federal Reserve and it led to
speculation about the future of the gold
standard I this next one is a big one
it's it's one you push around bad things
happen to use the military industrial
complex which Eisenhower warned against
this and one of his speeches here's what
he said in the councils of government we
must guard against the acquisition of
unwarranted influence whether sought or
unsought by the military industrial
complex
the potential for the disastrous rise of
misplaced power exists and will persist
we must never let the weight of this
combination endanger our liberties or
Democratic processes
we should take nothing for granted
only an alert and knowledgeable
citizenry can compel the proper meshing
of the huge industrial and Military
Machinery of Defense with our peaceful
methods and goals so JFK saw this and he
continued the criticism of the
military-industrial complex and he
wanted to reduce its influence he wanted
to ensure that the military was not used
for economic or political gain and JFK
had constant disagreements with his
advisors about the Vietnam War and was
reluctant to get involved in the war but
he was eventually persuaded by his
advisors to send military advisers to
South Vietnam however he was always
opposed to sending combat troops to
Vietnam and he reportedly wanted to find
a way to end the war without escalating
through American involvement the next
one was the establishment candidate
Lyndon Johnson who could not stand John
F Kennedy because John F Kennedy was
everything Lyndon Johnson wanted to be
Charming charismatic great speaker
people loved him and Lyndon Johnson
didn't have that but Lyndon Johnson was
more ambitious he wanted to be a
president so bad John F Kennedy really
didn't want to be a president was his
dad's Vision that eventually became his
vision but Lyndon it was his vision I
want to be in power one day let me give
you a couple examples of why this is
important handling of the Cuban Missile
Crisis Kennedy and Johnson disagreed
about how to respond to the Soviet
Union's placement of nuclear missiles in
Cuba Kennedy wanted to make a more
cautious approach while Johnson wanted
to take a more aggressive approach to
Vietnam War Kennedy and Johnson also
disagreed about the war Kennedy had
authorized the sending of military
advisers to Vietnam but he had not
authorized the sending of combat troops
Johnson on the other hand escalated the
war by sending combat troops to Vietnam
by the way right after John F Kennedy
was assassinated you know what Lyndon
Johnson did he escalated American
involvement in the war immediately
sending troops to Vietnam and he
committed the United States to a war
that lasted an entire decade the next
one was the oil companies that John F
Kennedy wanted to go up against and
obviously they're not going to be too
happy about it but remember the oil
companies had a friend and Ally his name
was Lyndon Johnson which he was from
Texas and this John F Kennedy keeps
getting in the way of these guys making
money John F Kennedy was very critical
of oil companies and wanted to regulate
them more effectively he believed that
the oil companies were too powerful full
and we're not accountable to the
American people RFK AG of the U.S used
the Department of Justice to investigate
and prosecute oil companies RFK was a
strong critic of the oil industry and
they believed that the companies were
engaged in anti-competitive practices
the doj's Anti-Trust division this
lawsuit led to the largest Anti-Trust
settlement in the history at the time
and it forced the oil companies to
change their business practices and last
but not least was the Cold War which it
kind of links to the CIA and it kind of
links to military industrial complex you
want to take a completely different
approach with Russia and here's what it
was during the Cuban Missile Crisis the
NSA wanted Kennedy to bomb Cuban harshly
retaliate against the USSR but the
speech President Kennedy gave at
American University on June 10 1963 was
a major departure from the Cold War
rhetoric at the time in this speech JFK
called for a re-examination of American
attitudes towards the Soviet Union and a
new approach to peace he also proposed
several specific steps to reduce
tensions between the two superpowers
including a ban on nuclear testing and a
joint space program this infuriated a
lot of people in the intelligence
agencies and Military so you're probably
still asking a question Pat I this is
crazy I understand it's a great episode
where are you going with this is this a
political message on who I should vote
for I think I kind of read between the
lines here's all I'm saying to you Elon
Musk part of the anti-establishment
Steve Jobs Steve Wozniak Apple
anti-establishment political people
Reagan Kennedy Trump Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders was
originally part of the
anti-establishment until he caved and he
said I can't do this why because it's
hard it's hard it sucks it's tough It's
lonely before everybody shows up but you
stay true to your values and principles
and if that's important to you you got
to do the fight and by the way yes when
it comes down to political uh
affiliation who you vote for you got to
look for this if you don't a great
country like America or whatever country
you're a part of the more and more and
more The Establishment controls it the
more and more and more it goes away from
what it was founded on let me explain it
to you I'm going to give you three
examples to validate my point by the way
before anybody says anything there's
nothing about this message that's about
going and breaking the laws zero
breaking the rules yes breaking the laws
that's not what we're talking about
three examples of what happens
Vanderbilt made so much money was the
richest man in the world you know how
many generations the money lasted too
you know why because the second
generation was spoiled they didn't know
what to do with the money America right
now started off for what going against
the establishment what was the
establishment British establishment like
listen leave us alone we want freedom
boom we win we're free but we have to
earn that freedom you and I in America
we ain't fighting for that freedom the
way they fought for the freedom but we
still have to fight for this freedom but
some of the people are just kind of like
warm and fuzzy well I'm part of the
establishment I'll give you another one
Hollywood look what Hollywood did well
Hollywood isn't at The Establishment
today today it is when Hollywood first
got started in the 20s and they moved
from New Jersey New Jersey yes Thomas
Edison had all these controls on the
entertainment industry they said we're
leaving Jersey we're going to Hollywood
why because they were sick of the
establishment guess what Hollywood is
today the establishment do you know in
1920s 95 percent of movies in America
were made in Hollywood you know what it
is today 55 why because Hollywood has
become an establishment stay alert stay
alive pay very close attention to your
industry to your family to your peers to
your government to the economy every
single thing you look at stay alert stay
alive and do whatever you can to not be
part of the oblivious Community graduate
that I was part of that for a very very
long time and find a way to be part of
the untraditional free thinking
anti-alite this is the way we've always
done it and then Freedom will continue
for the Next Generation but you and I
got some fighting to do makes sense
anyways got you thinking you're probably
going to a completely different place
right now that's fine if you got value
out of this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel If it creates
controversy and conversation share it
with others and debate each other and if
you like this video I got another video
I want you to watch
is how to go up against the Goliath the
anti-establishment of your industry
you've never seen this video click here
to watch it take care everybody bye-bye
foreign
[Music]